today we're going to talk about the six
mistakes that you could make
drinking water so let's start with the
first one drinking too much water now is
this possible yes it is especially when
you force yourself to drink all this
water especially without the
electrolytes that help you
deal with this extra water and i know
there's a lot of gurus out there that
say the most important thing you need to
keep drinking drinking drinking a lot of
water right
as that's the absolute most important
thing you can do
you should drink a gallon of water a day
well that's fine but are you exercising
are you sweating are you taking
electrolytes are you taking enough sea
salt what happens when you drink
too much water you can dilute
electrolytes specifically salt
and you can create a condition called
hypopatremia where there's not enough
sodium in your blood
and that actually is a form of
dehydration so it is possible that
drinking too much water can put you in a
situation where you're dehydrated and i
just want to make a point i'm not
against water you just need to drink the
right amount hopefully you have the
sensation of thirst that can tell you
when you're thirsty now on the flip side
if you are prone to kidney stones you
should be drinking at least two and a
half liters of fluid a day because the
kidney stone develops in a super
saturated concentration of urine so if
you're drinking enough water um it's
almost impossible to develop a stone and
so should we all drink exactly eight
glasses of water a day it really depends
on a lot of variables that i'm going to
get into in this video so the point of
number one is just make sure you're not
forcing yourself to drink
gallons of water because people have
died from the condition called
hyponatremia and i will put that link
down below all right number two
drinking water too quickly now this is
not like a major point it's a minor
point but when you drink water too fast
sometimes the sodium in your blood
doesn't have a chance to help balance
this fluid and that's one of sodium's
jobs is to help balance fluid inside and
outside the cell and so when you're
forcing too quickly too much water in
your body
that can actually create some swelling
especially if it's a lot of water
because of what happens to sodium sodium
will start going into the cell too fast
and you'll be deficient outside the cell
so it creates this in balance situations
so when you drink water do it at a pace
that is not too fast all right number
three
having this idea that you're getting all
your hydration from other fluids like
coffee
tea
maybe alcohol which completely
dehydrates you soda which is completely
dehydrating and yes there are certain
people out there that think that soda
hydrates you it doesn't so when you're
drinking like coffee and tea realize
that both of those have a mild diuretic
effect so they can be pushing fluid out
of your body and not necessarily
hydrating you and also if you're on a
diuretic on top of that and you're
pushing all this fluid out of your body
it can make you very dehydrated and so
what you drink is a factor to look at
and there's other variables to look at
as well
what is the temperature outside if
you're living in an environment that's
very hot
you're probably going to need more fluid
if you're exercising and you're sweating
a lot you're going to need a lot of
fluids if you have a condition where
you're not exercising but you sweat a
lot that's another factor if you're
experiencing diarrhea or vomiting both
of those conditions can very quickly
dehydrate you if you just started the
ketogenic diet and you're dumping a lot
of extra fluid
that's something to look at because all
that stored sugar in your muscles and
your liver also retains a lot of fluid
for every gram of stored glucose you're
storing three grams of water so when
you're on a high carb diet you're
basically a fluid filled sponge
and when you start reducing your carbs
that fluid just starts coming out and so
if you're not taking the right
electrolytes with enough fluid you can
potentially become dehydrated especially
when you start keto now another factor
that i want to bring up that a lot of
people don't consider
is if you're consuming a lot of
potassium as in an electrolyte drink
with a lot of potassium
if you're not also taking enough sodium
potentially with all these other factors
you can become more dehydrated now the
only reason i'm bringing that up is
because i personally have a electrolyte
powder that's high in potassium but it
also has a good amount of sodium and
salts so typically that's not going to
be a problem but
if you're exercising a lot and it's hot
outside and you're sweating and your
diet doesn't have enough salt let's say
you don't put any salt you know it's
something to look at because potassium
is balanced out with sodium you need the
right ratios but on the flip side
the most common situation is where
someone is not getting enough potassium
because they're not eating enough
vegetables they're heavier on the salts
they have more fluid retention they're
usually always deficient in potassium
and so doing more potassium tends to
help them all right number four
drinking a good amount of water when
you're eating that can dilute your
gastric juices like hydrochloric acid
and if you already have a weakness
within this area you don't have enough
stomach acid or it's not acid enough
which is very common especially if
you're over the age of 45
drinking more water with your meals will
dilute your ability to digest
especially protein
and you may end up with gerd or acid
reflux so i always recommend if you're
going to drink with a meal
just don't overdo it it's better if you
drink maybe a half hour before the meal
or a half hour
later but i don't want to make this a
really big point if you are thirsty in a
meal go ahead and drink but the point is
if you're already deficient in the
gastric juices
drinking more water will weaken your
stomach's ability to digest protein all
right number five
drinking extremely cold water in large
amounts can inhibit the vagus nerve now
this is a minor point this is not a big
point some people can drink a lot of
cold water no problem but if your
digestive system is already weak let's
say you have you get a lot of bloating
or you have a lot of digestive issues
and you drink a good amount of ice cold
water that can slow down the vagus nerve
which is responsible for digestion all
right and number six
drinking tap water now some people will
say that drinking tap water is safe
but they're finding all sorts of things
in tap water that are not safe not to
mention the normal chlorine and fluoride
but also glyphosate which is
the chemical roundup ready that is
involved with the gmo foods you have
chemicals that affect fertility
hormones your brain you have chemicals
that are carcinogenic and on top of that
there's a lot of nano
size particles very small particles of
plastics that you're getting when you're
drinking tap water so just get a good
filter to filter that out now since
we're on the topic of water if you have
not seen my video
on how water affects your skin
you should check that out i put it right
here it's a really important video